Stanley is a pop-culture Titan with a
career that spans eight decades he's
been around long enough to see
characters he co-created become
household names a roster that includes
spider-man the x-men the Hulk and more
his journey has been remarkable but it
might not be what you'd expect from the
smiling spokesman for Marvel Comics
stand the delivery man Lieber we was
born Stanley Martin Lieber the son of
Jewish immigrants from Romania as a
student he worked odd jobs to help his
family get through the tail end of the
Great Depression including delivering
sandwiches in Manhattan a far cry from
his dreams of writing sci-fi novels not
long after graduating high school at 16
however he got a job at a company run by
one of his relatives Martin Goodman a
little place called timely comics
Stanley Brno born when he joined up with
timely comics in 1939 Stanley birth
ought that his job as an errand boy
would be a stepping-stone to a career as
a novelist
needless to say things turned out a
little differently in 1941 Stan was
assigned to write a text-only story as
filler for Captain America comics number
three for this story Captain America
foils the traitors revenge he used the
pseudonym Stanley intending to save his
real name for his future career as a
serious novelist within months the
imaginative new kid was off creating
superheroes of his own with names like
Jack Frost and father time just before
Lee turned 19 Captain America's creators
Joe Simon and Jack Kirby left over a
dispute with Goodman and Lee was named
interim editor before his career could
really take off though World War two
would force him into a brief detour
soldiers stand Stan Lee joined the US
Army in 1942 where his talent with words
led to assignments writing training
manuals and slogans for posters before
long he ended up in the Army's training
film division writing scripts and as he
would later recount he was one of only
nine people in the entire army whose
title was listed as playwright while
serving in the Army Stan continued to
send in scripts for time Lee's popular
titles and when the war ended Lee only
23 years old reclaimed the job as editor
and wouldn't give it up for decades but
not before thinking about quitting
entirely reinventing superheroes by the
1950s controversy or the contents in
comic books had been raging for years to
the point where publishers like mad
magazines bill Gaines were called to
testify before the Senate the result was
the comics code
set of regulations that put several
publishers out of business and limited
the kinds of stories creators could tell
faced with declining sales a lack of
respect for comics and the restrictions
of the code Lee was demoralized enough
to quit fortunately his wife Joan
convinced him to try something new
inspired by their competitions recent
success with putting their biggest
heroes into a team book called Justice
League of America Stan formed a team of
his own partnering with Jack Kirby to
create the Fantastic Four in November of
1961 the rebranded Marvel Comics
launched with Fantastic Four number one
introducing readers to a superhero team
that combines sci-fi origins with
relatable personalities in between
battling supervillains and
interdimensional threats the team
bickered fought and acted like you'd
expect regular flawed people with
superpowers to act the immediate success
led Goodman to order basically as many
new characters and comic books as lee
kirby and the other Marvel artists could
come up with
before long the Marvel bullpen was known
to the world with Stan the man Lee's
jovial editorials making him the
friendly face of the Marvel Age of
comics amazing fantasies as a kid Stan
Lee had been a fan of a pulp magazine
character called the spider which gave
him the idea to approach Goodman about
introducing a teen character with spider
themed powers we would later recall that
this idea was meant with some pretty big
skepticism from Goodman nobody wanted me
to do it my publisher when I suggested
the idea he said that's the worst thing
I ever heard people hate spiders
rather than risking a whole new series
on the wild idea Lee instead decided to
try his character out in amazing fantasy
a series that was due to be canceled
anyway with Kirby proving to be a bad
fit for the character artist Steve Ditko
took a crack at it instead and the world
was introduced to Peter Parker the
amazing spider-man after amazing fantasy
number 15 went flying off the shelves
Spidey was quickly given his own series
paving the way for another wave of
Marvel heroes marvel hits Hollywood by
the 21st century the Marvel Cinematic
Universe would be breaking box-office
records but Marvel's and Stan's original
road to Hollywood was actually a lot
more difficult than they expected in the
70s there were plenty of attempts at
bringing Marvel properties to television
the amazing spider-man debuted on CBS as
a TV movie in 1977 and while the
technical limitations were obvious fans
seemed thrilled to have a live-action
version of the webslinger airing and
time it didn't last though CBS pulled
the plug after 13 episodes because of
its more successful Marvel adaptation
The Incredible Hulk featuring Bill Bixby
is dr. banner and Lou Ferrigno is
rampaging alter ego The Incredible Hulk
aired for five seasons and helped to
cement the character in the pop-culture
consciousness
unfortunately the attempts at launching
Doctor Strange and Captain America
through TV movies didn't work out and
Marvel's hard luck got worse when the
entire comics industry hit a slump in
the 90s through it although Stan
continued to be an ambassador for the
brand and while it had been years since
he'd actually been an editor at Marvel a
new wave of Marvel films in 2000 led to
what has today become his signature the
well-placed cameo shoot the heroes in
New York in the face of Marvel since the
beginning of Marvel's rise to
pop-culture dominance over 50 years ago
Stan Lee's face and personality have
only grown more associated with the
brand
he's lent his voice to video games and
cartoons appeared in almost every Marvel
movie and even writes the occasional new
comic story for Marvel it all became
possible because a creative kid with an
illustrious background in sandwich
delivery and a struggling young industry
took a chance on each other and because
of Joan Lee the greatest advice-giver
there ever was excelsior
you know I guess one person and
difference
enough said
[Music]